le docteur yacine tandjaoui lambie au
dessus médecins hospitaliers en public
dans un hôpital universitaire de l'ap-hp
qui s'appelle hôpital avicenne qui est
un gros hôpital de la seine-saint-denis
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
beaucoup beaucoup de soignants beaucoup
de médecins des différences de publique
de seine-saint-denis de six hôpitaux
différents qui est qui agrège leur lutte
pour exprimer la difficulté que connaît
le talent public aujourd'hui et rappelé
la ministre de la santé et des
solidarités que le plan qu'elle a
proposé pour essayé de réanimer le
public est malheureusement totalement
insuffisant tellement insuffisant que on
estime qu' on ne pourra pas on ne pourra
pas faire des soins dignes et de qualité
en sécurité pour les patients et en
sécurité pour les soignants
malgré le plan qu'elle a prononcées et
donc pour signifier notre désaccord une
autre information
beaucoup de médecins qui sont en
responsabilité administrative des
médecins qui sont loin d'être des
inconséquences des irresponsables ont
pris la difficile décision très
difficile très lourde de démissionner de
leurs tâches administratives ou de se
mettre en retrait leurs tâches
administratives et une vague de
démissions qui existe partout en france
et c'est le cas aussi dans le
département c'est un département qui
souffre particulièrement
d'une part parce que il est sous
dimensionné au niveau des soins
d'autre part parce que la population y
est dans une difficulté sociale que tout
le monde connaît alors qu'à population
très importante on a quasiment 1 2
million d'habitants dans le département
est donc aujourd'hui il ya un peu plus
de 75 chefs de service responsable
structures élues la communauté médicale
qui ont pris la très lourde décision de
se mettre en retrait de leurs tâches
administratives ce qu'il veut mais bien
sûr en continu assurer les soins parce
qu'il est absolument impensable que
priver nos patients des soins qui leur
sont absolument nécessaires et donc à
défaut de faire la grève du soin ont
fait une grève administrative
d'où cette vague de mises en retrait
c'est à des démissions
difficultés et les majeures avec notre
gouvernement mais si on va tout à fait
honnête c'est pas un problème de ce
gouvernement mais des gouvernements
successifs depuis le début des années
2000 il ya une politique budgétaire qui
applique à l'hôpital en france qui est
malheureusement extrêmement délétère
pour l'hôpital public délétère parce que
on a volontairement délibérément sous
financer l'hôpital et ce sous
financement entraîne des restrictions
budgétaires partout ce que propose
actuellement le gouvernement comme soi
disant plan de sauvetage est totalement
insuffisant c'est à dire qu' il n'y a
même pas de quoi éviter de faire des
économies avec ce qu'a proposé la
ministre de la santé au mois de novembre
l'hôpital doit continuer de faire des
économies on continue encore aujourd'hui
et malgré ce plan si on n'arrive même
pas à l' équilibre pour ne pas faire
d'économies comment vous expliquez c'est
que la santé ça coûte très cher ça coûte
très très cher et c'est pour ça que ce
qu'on demande on demande bien sûr de
l'argent mais ce qu'on demande c'est
surtout un grenelle de la santé c'est à
dire en fait que la décision elle soit
celle de la société celle du peuple
français de déterminer quel type de
médecine quel type de santé veut la
nation de ce pays et si on veut avoir
une médecine publique de qualité qui
permettent d'être à la fois une médecine
de recours aux médecines des expertises
métiers d'excellence il permettra
l'accès aux soins pour tous alors il
faut la financer
et actuellement on a finance pas